okay so in this video we're going to go
over some of the basic chemistry behind
water and some of the principles and
properties of water molecules so let's
go ahead and get started so first of all
few basics about water one of the most
important features of water is that it's
an example of what we call a polar
molecule polar means that the molecule
is one area of the molecule is slightly
positive while another area of the same
molecule is slightly negative so water
is a molecule and a portion of the water
molecule will have a negative charge and
another portion will have a positive
charge and let's show you how that works
so you should know that water is made
from hydrogen and oxygen and the trick
to water being Polar's this right here
oxygen is going to hog the electrons
from hydrogen now oxygen normally has
eight protons and eight electrons but
it's going to hog and kind of take two
electrons from the two hydrogen's
bringing its total up to ten that's
going to give it a negative charge so if
I draw first of all two electrons on the
inside electron level of oxygen in red
and six electrons in the second level
because oxygen only has eight electrons
total by itself eight electrons it's
going to grab two more electrons for a
total of ten but on its own oxygen only
has eight
well now let's focus our attention for a
moment on hydrogen hydrogen has one
proton so that means it has one electron
but my notes say that it has zero
electrons will that mean that that's
because after Elect after oxygen kind of
grabs the electron hydrogen really won't
have any so naturally hydrogen has one
blue electron there and another blue
electron so hydrogen naturally has one
electron well you know what let's set
these electrons in motion and what I
mentioned is that oxygen is going to
grab those two electrons in blue
from the hydrogen so watch what I mean
by that oxygen is going to grab those
two electrons and now it has a total of
10 it's got eight of its own and then
the ninth and tenth in blue that it just
grabbed from hydrogen so that's going to
give water its polarity and again what
we mean by that it has a positive notice
how the hydrogen now has a positive
charge because it's got a proton but no
electrons oxygen now has a negative
charge because it has eight protons but
10 electron and so this creates what we
call a hydrogen barn where one water
molecule sticks to another and so here
we have two water molecules bond it
together
with a hydrogen bond and you know a big
collection of water it's just a big
collection of these hydrogen bonds here
and so you can see in every hydrogen
bond the positive hydrogen is connected
to the negative oxygen when we look at a
big container for water here we have a
bunch of about eight water molecules
nine water molecules across the top and
I labeled them positive and negative and
when we look at water water is arranged
in layers you know water has depth to it
and so when we look at the water
molecules underneath the first layer we
can see how the positive the positive
hydrogen's are connected and bonded to
the negative oxygens same with the third
level the third layer of water is you
know you can see the positive connected
to the negative and the same goes as we
continue all the way down so water
arranges itself in this little
configuration here whenever you have a
pool or a puddle or a container full of
water couple properties to mention about
water besides water being polar well
because water is polar it has what's
called a high specific heat then this
simply means that it will resist
temperature changes in the picture you
can see a pot of boiling water so it
takes a lot of energy it takes a lot of
energy to break the
turns and boil water in this case in the
picture you know takes several minutes
over an open flame to generate enough
heat to to make that water boil now if
we look at this little animation here
you can see a pot of water sitting on
top of of an open flame and what what
happens is as the temperature increases
the bonds in between the water molecules
break and as the barns in between the
water molecules break you know gas water
gas water vapor steam simply Rises into
the air
but it takes energy to break those bonds
that hold water molecules together so
because waters temperature is very
difficult to change this helps our body
maintain a nice constant temperature in
the picture we have some track-and-field
athletes you know in in the middle of
doing an exercise or run but at the end
of their race you know their body
temperature really hasn't changed much
even though they were working very hard
their bodies is made mostly from water
as is all of our bodies and so because
our bodies is made mostly from water the
temperature of our body just really
doesn't change very much and when our
body temperature does change you might
end up in bed with a little bit of the
temperature a little bit of a fever
because again our our temperature is so
vital to our health another feature I
want to mention of water because water
is polar it water has what's called
cohesion and and we can see in this
picture a great example of cohesion so
how come this paperclip is able to stay
on top of water you can see the
paperclip is not falling through well
the answer is pretty straightforward
is that paperclip is not heavy enough
that paperclip does not have enough
weight to break the hydrogen bonds that
holds water molecules together cohesion
is where one water molecule sticks to
another one sticks to another and sticks
to another and six to another so when we
look at that picture that we saw earlier
here's that picture from earlier and if
we put a big ol paperclip on top of it
the paperclip is just not heavy enough
to break apart the hydrogen bonds that
that are attaching the individual water
molecules together and the final water
propio I want to mention because water
is polar water has what's called
adhesion and so every year sometimes
students will mix up cohesion and
adhesion and cohesion is when water
sticks to water adhesion is where water
sticks to things other than water and in
this picture here we have a red liquid
filled into a graduated cylinder and if
you've ever seen this before you might
notice that there's a little dip in the
in the water level in the liquid level
this dip by the way is called the
meniscus so if you ever reading a
graduated cylinder do you read the
bottom of the meniscus in this example
where it says 25 milliliters or do you
read the top of the meniscus in this
example where it says 29 milliliters I
hope you know from from experience the
answer is you would read the bottom in
this case there's 25 milliliters of that
red liquid now the reason I'm bringing
this up you can see adhesion in this
example because the water inside of the
graduated cylinder is staying to the
glass of the graduated cylinder and it's
causing that little dip right there
so because of water's polarity because
of water water has that polar charge
positive and negative charge it's able
to stick to things so one thing I want
to now shift our attention to is focus
on solutions if you've ever mixed up for
instance Crystal Light or kool-aid or
lemonade you've made made yourself a
homemade solution a solution is a
mixture that's a mixture where one
substance will dissolve in another
substance you might know that solutions
are made from two parts first part of a
solution I want to mention is called the
solute these are the substances that are
going to dissolve in a biological
solution you might find atoms and ions
and molecules these are things that are
dissolved inside of a solution now in my
picture here
crystallite kool-aid country time
lemonade you know the powdered drinks
even powdered Gatorade you know you mix
them with water well what happens to the
powder once you put it in water the
powder dissolves the powder from these
drinks right here is a great example of
a solute so the other part of a solution
is what we call it a solvent it's the
substance that is causing the solute to
dissolve and that's usually going to be
water water is pretty much our universal
solvent here and so when we look at a
silly example a childhood example of a
solution here we have sugar mixed with
kool-aid in our little container of
water here you know you get a spoon and
you stir it all together and what
happens to the sugar what happens to the
kool-aid they dissolve they break apart
and dissolve and you have a sweet sugary
drink you know from your childhood but
this is a great example kool-aid and
lemonade and Crystal Light these are
great examples of solutions
what about biologicals a great example
of a biological solution is simply our
blood you know here's a picture of a
test tube with a little stopper on it
filled with blood and a neat little
thing you can do to separate the parts
of blood is if you stick blood in a
centrifuge which is a machine that just
spins the test tube around and around
and around really really fast
after a few moments the blood the
components of blood will separate and
you can really see that blood is a great
example of a solution on top you have
the plasma which is the watery part of
the blood water again is pretty much our
universal solvent in the middle we have
a real thin layer of white blood cells
WBC's and platelets will talk more about
white blood cells and platelets in
another video and at the bottom of the
test tube are the heavier parts the the
white excuse me the red blood cells and
and so you can really see that blood is
a great example of a solution when you
when you centrifuge it like this blood
is made from
event which we set a moment ago plasma
is the watery part of blood that makes
plasma because it's based mostly made
from water that makes plasma your
solvent and also there are solutes in
your blood the carbohydrates the
proteins the sugars these are all these
are all molecules that are dissolved in
your plasma in your watery part of your
blood well whenever we talk about
solutions of course we're going to
mention the pH scale and so what the pH
scale it measures the amount of hydrogen
ions that a solution contains and you
might know from the scale here that
everything below a 7 on the pH scale is
considered an acid and acids have more
hydrogen ions they and but the above 7
is what we call a base well bases have a
lot of something else just not hydrogen
ions you can see bases have very few
hydrogen ions but bases have a lot of
what are called hydroxide ions that's
what the O H is a symbol for it's an ion
called hydroxide made up of hydrogen and
oxygen acids you can see have very few
hydroxide ions right in the middle of
our pH scale is our neutral 7 and then
you know if we were in class I would
give you some time to try to answer
these questions with your neighbor if
you're watching at home pause the video
and try to answer question a B and C I'm
going to go over the answer in 3 2 1
question a which base has the most h+
hydrogen ions i hope you see that's
blood which base is really only gives us
three choices blood baking soda and
ammonia question b which substance has
the fewest hydrogen ions from all from
all the choices you can see that that
would be ammonia it's farthest to the
right and because it's farthest to the
right it has the fewest h+ hydrogen ions
question c which is the strongest acid
while there's really only three to two
from lemons soft drinks and milk those
are three acids which one is the
strongest well that would be lemons and
that's a little weird because you can
see the pH of lemons is about 2.3 on the
scale and milk is six point four and
we're used to bigger numbers being
stronger but in this case the two point
three is farther from neutral that's why
it's stronger so moving on with our pH
scale when molecules are when substances
are dissolved they will often release
hydrogen ions and watching this little
animation here we're going to put
substance a into this container of let's
say water and over time substance a is
going to dissolve and release hydrogen
ions well this solution is now acidic we
said a moment ago from the pH scale
acids have a higher collection a higher
concentration of hydrogen ions well the
opposite is true with bases if we put
for instance substance B into this
liquid here and over time substance B
dissolves and releases those hydroxide
those OHS this is what forms an alkaline
solution or a basic solution and one
thing to mention about the final thing I
want to mention about pH is the reason
we're talking about it in these notes is
because we said that blood is a great
example of a solution and the pH of
blood is really important and vital to
our life our notes say that Bloods pH is
naturally about 7.4 that makes blood a
very very weak very very weak base
naturally and what happens is if we do
things to change the pH of our blood
proteins that are normally in our blood
begin to break down and ultimately a
person could die from this so we want to
of course avoid actions that cause our
pH of blood to change well one of the
most common actions that causes the pH
of blood to change
is alcohol use in this picture here we
see a blood vein with a nice balance of
hydrogen and hydroxide ions and normally
blood is very slightly basic but when a
person abuses alcohol you can see in my
animation here a larger collection of
hydrogen ions begin to accumulate as the
person drinks more and more and more
their blood gathers more and more of
these hydrogen ions this makes their
blood instead of a nice 7.4 slightly
basic this brings the pH down into the
acid range and ultimately can cause
internal chemical reactions to stop and
a person could actually die from alcohol
poisoning if they drink too much well
let's say that a person is at least
drinking responsibly and they stop and
over time your kidneys are supposed to
remove those excess amounts of hydrogen
ions and that brings your pH back to
normal
the people of the problem is people who
have a history a lifetime of alcohol
abuse often have kidney damage and so
they're not able to remove those
hydrogen ions and their blood pH can be
off and that could cause some very
serious health effects and so as we wrap
up this video if you're in my biology
class pause the video I'd be happy to
check your answers for accuracy either
before school or after school so go
ahead and pause the video and try to
answer these good luck